now the network section of the cache
manifest contains files that explicitly
need a network connection for example we
can't really cache the google analytics
page because the connection is important
if you have an image resource that's a
live webcam image or some other kind of
data that has to be loaded over the
network putting that resource in this
section will bypass the app cache and
try loading the resource from the
network even while it's offline and
finally the fallback section is where
you set up appt cash alternatives for
resources that need to come from the
network for example that live webcam
image maybe you want to cache an old
version of it the browser will use the
rules in this section to load an
alternative but only after trying to
load the resource from the network first
for that reason you should use the
fallback section sparingly because it
will wait for a network timeout